great civilizations rise they peak and
they fall Troy Atlantis the Roman Empire
and chazz chazz chop also known as soy
Mallya and vegans way Lea and the Soviet
Union it is no more but its memory will
last forever for generation unto
generation we will take a look back at a
few of the Funniest Home Videos from the
Capitol Hill autonomous zone and select
the absolute best to kick it off
Chaz leaders call for a savior oh if
there are any white people who feel who
have experience and security and can
maybe talk to this gentleman it really
isn't the type of thing
black people to handle a situation so
listen to the way she puts it she says
are there any white people with
experience in security to stop this
whoever this person is some criminal I
guess was running running wild jizz
that's not the responsibility of black
people to deal with this guy so you're
saying you want a white person with
experience in security also known as a
cop in the autonomous zone created
specifically to get rid of all the white
cops that was a firt I think that might
have been the first moment when they
thought maybe this idea of ours is not
totally coherent next up admiring the
wonderful beautiful art of the Chazz
here is this is just another wall of our
art our our expression of our feelings
[Music]
well then he goes out they'd lose the
phone and then now you can see someone's
probably running with that phone
somebody's chasing him and that guy is
chasing him screaming thief so he is
admiring all of this beautiful art and
then all of a sudden in the beautiful
art of Chazz he gets mugged and someone
takes his beautiful art this is this is
the dream this is the Communist John
Lennon dream imagine there's no
possessions well okay that guy just
helped him imagine that they described a
conservative as a liberal very often who
has been mugged by reality that guy in
the chest just got mugged by reality he
also got mugged by an actual anarchist
and got his property stolen either way I
hope at least it has changed to his
views and put them more in line with
reality third up YouTube
a youtuber discovers the legendary
homeless rake ninja there was a brief
glimmer of hope when a gaggle of pot
heads dumped topsoil on sheets of
cardboard and called it a garden albeit
for blacks only then their plant allies
holy Sh
but this was quickly taken over and
claimed as his own autonomous zone by a
homeless rake ninja
[Music]
that's not gonna be good for the crops
that nope I don't know that the crops
are gonna grow very well anyway but it
was taken over this is actually the
problem of the autonomous zone is it all
comes from liberalism and this idea that
you've always got to be liberating
yourself and getting more and more
autonomous so okay the the autonomous
zone creates its own country within the
country but by its own logic there could
easily be another autonomous zone within
the autonomous zone right there's no end
to the oppression and the greatest
revolutionary of all of them would
appear to be the rake ninja far more so
than all those anarchists who are
running their tops of art and finally
fear of the law and order of chess
what's your deal why you down here
keeping a board or a wall between you no
cops
whoever wants to hurt these people
period are people trying to hurt them
not as far as I've been here I've only
been standing out here for about 12
hours do you live here um I live all
around here I don't have a home so so
we're now safe because a guy with a
haircut out of a 1990s video game and a
bunch of anarchist stickers on his shirt
some bum some vomit is what is he in his
20s or 30s he is going to be the
neighborhood watch now
this one is a great bookend from the
first video which is that Chas chop
decides it's gonna be its own country
it's gonna be this utopia it's going to
be unlike that awful conservative place
run by Donald Trump with a bunch of cops
and border walls and what do they do
they immediately make their own cops and
border walls I would say though my
favorite probably has to be the first
one because it is so oblivious it is so
tone-deaf to say this whole movement is
is based on getting rid of white cops
and then immediately they say please
please hey we didn't mean it we didn't
mean it forget utopia which really means
no place and that's what Chaz is as of
now no place r.i.p CH AZ
[Music]
[Music]